here's one more weird thing I found
while doing the Grimace video so this
tweet is from December 2020. this is
allegedly a toy at McDonald's the guy
says toys at McDonald's are getting
weird this is the Grimace toy I just got
how do you even play with this and I
have to agree with him how do you play
with this this uh quote-unquote Toy I do
find it a little weird that he says this
is the Grimace toy I just got and he
appears to be an adult not the the toy
that my kid just got or younger sibling
just got or something like that let's
look at some of the replies I know a few
people who know exactly how to play with
this from miss metal I think maybe miss
metal needs to delete her account
apparently this person has it all
figured out because he or she says
you'll figure it out and then you'll
know why he's called grimace